okay just got back from getting my
haircut I thought I should probably tell
you this before we start the vlog just
had two shots of rum with my Greek and
Barber he took the shots to the shots
before the haircut so he you know had
those scissors up by my ears coffee on a
Tuesday and vlog 37 3d movies please
just stop making them so last week the
new Judge Dredd movie came out and I was
excited because it looked like the Old
Faithful Fair of gratuitous slow-motion
violence and explosions and the 1995 one
was Stallone is Bowser so I was ready to
Fandango some tix when my friend and
general sad news Susan Elias told me
that it was only showing in 3d only 3d
surely there has to be a 2d showing
somewhere so I think it's probably a
good time to talk about why I don't like
the troubling new trend of 3d movies I
saw avatar in 3d I saw Coraline in 3d
but I had I had to cut it off there
because for both of those movies it was
like after 45 minutes a finger started
pushing into the center of my forehead
maybe this happens to you too and if it
does I can tell you there is a good
reason and it has to do with evolution
so when we look at something anything
there are a few things that are
happening with our eyes first like a
camera your eyes are focusing at a
certain distance you can imagine focus
is sort of like a flat plane that's
moving away from you depending on what
you're looking at second and unlike a
camera your eyes are converging on a
point the object of your gaze this
convergence is the third point in a
triangle in which the other two points
are your eyes triangle for the hundreds
of thousands of years that humans have
been pottering around and for the many
more millions of years in the history of
eyes the focus point and the convergence
point have always been the same but when
you're sitting in a theater watching a
3d movie things are a bit different the
focus point always remains the
always say 60 feet where the screen is
but the convergence point is always
changing depending on what the director
wants you to see the image might be 30
feet away it might be a hundred feet
away it's variable now we can do this
but it takes our brains a few more
milliseconds to adjust to the change
this is why editing in 3d films is a
little bit slower than norm as Walter
Murch the legendary film editor and
sound designer says the CPU of our
perceptual brain has to work extra hard
which is why after 20 minutes or so
people get headaches they're doing
something that 600 million years of
evolution never prepared them for so if
you're getting headaches in 3d films
it's not your fault it's Charles
Darwin's fault no way for years I've
been to crying 3d movies not because of
the serious and seemingly insurmountable
focus convergence issue but because I
think that they perpetuate a false
equivalency I've never seen physical or
illusory immersiveness as the ruler of
what makes an immersive movie some of my
favorite 2d movies are pretty
3-dimensional in their own right and
nothing in those ever pops out of the
screen and this applies to gratuitous
action movies too I mean in order to
catch him he must become him huge
scissors is cutting by my ears and I was
like his xxx cut of the day so
yeah